breathe the rebound draymond green and
the Warriors upset after that loss the
other night as Thompson fires away
knocks down the three when they've been
five of their first 10 from the field
playing some good defense curry whips a
pass
Thompson creates some space second
three-pointer Thompson's got eight
points already fully but surely chipping
it away keeping with their defense and
the bench has been sensational play
Thompson for three 15 points in 12
minutes for klay Thompson incredible
numbers second in the NBA in assists the
turnover ratio he also did that as time
two hits another one just tuning in both
state raced out to a 19 point lead in
the first quarter
Thompson Turek a couple of plates Hudson
feeling it here tonight
big adela to Durant Thompson for three
[Applause]
[Music]
you know most organizations as Thompson
hits a incredible shot won't go down and
Durant with a rebound Thompson catching
shoes got it put in Thompson with 34
talked about they need to compete
barters play harder and that was evident
from the opening tip top sitting hit for
three his night three-pointer of the
game